l'imminence cette erreur de la nature
c'est un capitaine rongé par la colère
et un désir de vengeance face à une
baleine blanche symbole de la toute
puissance de la nature
le théâtre du nouveau monde a choisi
l'oeuvre moby dick pour entamer sa
nouvelle saison
une adaptation des auteurs bryan perro
et dominic champagne tout ce qui me
reste fort stoner et de courage se tient
péniblement sur une seule sans aucun
environnement de vermine melville paru
en 1851 le capitaine de bateau et
chasseurs de baleines à câble est
apprêté par normand d'amour le temps un
choix obsessif parce qu'il s'est fait
arracher la jambe et fait estropiés par
la baleine blanche et son but c'est de
la retrouver pour l'année attire comme
s'il portait en lui la somme de toute la
rage est prouvé par l'espèce humaine
comme dans le roman l'histoire nous est
racontée par un narrateur le personnage
et ismaël joué par steve gagnon désireux
de fuir sa réalité
ismaël s'engage sur le navire du
capitaine accable sans savoir ce qui
l'attend et il va trouver dans cette
aventure là la leçon où on n'échappe pas
au regard de l'éternel on n'échappe pas
à son destin
charlot acabit son équipage détruisent
l'environnement en chassant les baleines
dont l'huile cerd énergie combustible
dans une amérique qui s'industrialise ce
thème toujours d'actualité a touché une
corde sensible du metteur en scène qui
milite contre l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste on a soif de lumière on a besoin
d'énergie
on a soif de voyage et d'océans puis en
même temps mais notre appétit trop
gourmand trop glouton nous mène aussi à
des extrémités qui nous mène à notre
perte qui nous mène à notre naufrage au
final la nature aura raison de l'homme
la baleine blanche demeura maîtresse de
la mer mobi deck présentée au tnm à
montréal du 22 septembre au 17 octobre
sera en tournée québécoise à l'automne
ici valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal